>> Brendan: TAKING ON A COYOTES
TEAM THAT Brendan: THAT'S AWKWA
STOPPED BY ILYAO PLAY THIS GAME
YOU KNOW, NOT GET CLIPPED  COUL.
JOSH BAILEY
DYSIN MAYO.
PA
POINT-BLANK RANGE.
BAILEY TAKES IT THEDRIFTING.
NELSON BEHIND THE BACK OFF THE
BACK OF FOR ANTHONY
BEAUVILLIER CAN'T QUITE CLEAR
HIMSELF.
THE DAN.
IT'S AN EASY SHOT.
>> Brendan: NOT FOR ME.
HERE THE SCREEN.
WEDGEWOOD TRYING TO FIND  THE
BARZAL STILL ALONG THE
PERIMETER.
PAST
CZARNIK MOVES OFF TO THE
BRENDAN.
>> Brendan: 36 YEARS OLD IN HIS
17th NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE
SEASON.
ICE.
NOW ELBOWED OUT.
KEEPS IT GOINGNOCKED
AWAY FROM THE BOARD.
BOYD WHO PLAYED FOREAD THAT
THEY GRABBED IN THE FIRST
PERIOD.
MAYO AND NET.
HERE'S BAILEY IN FRONT.
GOOD POSITION.
NOT
COULDN'T DRIVE A PASS. LOOKED A
TRAINER.
A NELSON WITH
BEAUVILLIER.
HE SCORES.
TWO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THE TEAM WITH 12 GOALS.
DON'T FORGET. AHEAD OFIT.
PAGEAU WE KNOW LIKES TO GO  BAS
>> Brendan: PARISE OFF THE
BOARDS FOR SALO.
REPLAY.
ZACH HEADS TOWARD THE NET.
GOOD BOUNCE. GET
THROUGH.
EVERYBODY IS IN THE NET, AND AS
TRIPPED ON THE PLAY, SLIDING IN
AND SHOFLS DOW
HUR YCHL BROCK NELSON IN FRONT
OF THE NET.
THERE'S